and one of my homies texted me on my
[ __ ] says Amen there's some
[ __ ] out in the front door I go
get my street sweeper clothes open the
doors and there's three mess a's at my
door okay this is boxing right here
thank you so much
it's good to be here with y'all a man
it's it's been a minute since you know
we've seen each other but it's always
good to see you man and I gotta say it's
good to see you getting behind the
cannabis culture most of all cuz you
know it's more and more you see a lot of
athletes coming in and saying you know
what this [ __ ] is the business in terms
of what we want to use you know to make
ourselves better for our therapy for our
medicinal [ __ ] instead of that
over-the-counter crap they be yeah hey
man this is something I just have to
thank God for the Sun that came to me to
my brother's to my attention and I
thought this would be setting I do all
day till I die and this is something
that's it's very profitable and helping
people yeah and I wonder what I happen
to smoke with my whole box I stopped
smoking because I wanted to be a fighter
they test em Yeah right
and you know and it's it seems I have a
winner you know yeah
hey Mike did you do you think if you had
weed throughout your boxing career do
you think you would have been as
ferocious I don't know probably cuz you
know the weed [ __ ] with your mind and
makes you um when I smoke Pecha weights
who I am hmm yeah it's it's it's crazy
because with every individual it gives
you you know it's something different
right like everybody has a different
superpower with it you know so to speak
so like a lot of us get hyper focus so
like if you're stoned and you
working out in the gym you're like
totally zero they're not that's my
favorite focus yeah so I would think he
would been ferocious maybe that way but
yeah I think the the super hyper focus
would have been like right there but you
know what's cool now is that they're
looking into you know at least the
fighting game is in terms of the UFC I
think we're martial arts they're gonna
take that [ __ ] off the banlist yeah you
know it's crazy because all the athletes
get down like football players smoked in
the offseason baseball players
basketball players and we know that [ __ ]
for a fact because you know in my
smokebox interviews I've had some of
these athletes I've had like Al
Harrington you know come down and tell
us you know how [ __ ] get down
you know what I mean like how he got
down we just had Matt Barnes in there
we've had some MMA fighters come in Joe
Schilling and Kidd Rio any NFL guys
waiting I need a bigger car for the lawn
bro I need a bigger car cuz those dudes
are huge bring me in be cannabis
controlled the stress level man yeah
stress before you fight us well I'll
tell you this as a guy who played in the
NFL who you know cannabis was my
preferred pain management source
throughout my time in the league smoking
some weed was the one thing that would
just help me relax that felt better than
anything was the best thing it would
help me sleep I'd wake up the next day
and I'd be like [ __ ] I could do this
again well why am I taking this crap
yes making me feel worse at the end of
the day right no which which is what
usually happens because I mean you know
a lot of these things that they give
everyone you know are things to suppress
what's going on and not to cure yeah
right and in that suppression it makes
something else at your in your body
makeup or whatever you know that it it
creates a problem elsewhere for you
exactly I mean look at all these goddamn
commercials these days when it tell you
lipitor take this and then there's like
[ __ ] 50 [ __ ] side effects
including death that you got deal with
and that's half of this [ __ ]
that their their marketing on TV yeah
you know and androids in in in athletes
and and people just in general I think
are more educated now because you know
obviously the Internet has made
information readily readily available
there is no longer that you know you
could put this anti cannabis propaganda
out there and people not learn what the
real is and that's why a lot more people
have like let their guard down towards
cannabis you had Mothers Against Drunk
Driving and in other organizations that
were very much anti cannabis and when
they realize that their kids some of
them that were having a peptic seizures
and stuff like that they look to the see
a set the CBDs along with the THC one
like the Rick Simpson oils and whatnot
and how those things were helping you
know those kids with the seizures they
changed their stance on it and that was
huge because you know they started
educating other other mothers other
parents on how this actually helps in so
now you have people that smoke and
consume and you have advocates that
fight for but you also have allies in in
people that don't smoke in the but
they're in there and maybe weren't
advocates in the beginning but they see
how it really helps yeah and you know
that has created the wave of people like
getting involved in knowing that the
CBDs help in cannabis helps so hopefully
you know they take that [ __ ] off the
banlist and let these guys you know
medicate and I got to tell you there's
it's speaking of NFL players right I
have I have smoked out with to and I'm
trying to get one in the smoke box right
there's two mics I want to get in the
smoke boxers mr. Tyson right here you
know I'm saying and Mike Irvin Michael
Irvin he's a great oh and he chiefs he
Chiefs like a champion yeah he is a
champion no said but he Chiefs like one
two girls in and and he needs yeah he
needs it I mean they all need it yeah
all the guys who can only
you wanna try on try that with that
glass tip right there Mike that's called
the funky field tip right there
when you come to the smoke box I'm gonna
have a package of those way to meats in
dog that scent yeah he's awesome we had
a great time at Green Street he played
some amateur film I am I pro football
with rod Strickland or rot wait one of
the Raiders back in the day they they
had this league and it was some semi-pro
League it's awesome dog watching Dutch
documentary before I came here by a guy
named Dexter Manley right Dexter Manley
Redskins yeah he's an awesome guy I
remember seeing him when I was a kid
like in 83 or something like that hey I
gave him um he's in the courtroom and
they gave him a piece of paper to read
and he couldn't read the paper and he
started crying and I'm watching this and
I'm gonna said god I'm always um this
just made me got my game what was he
ready to read yeah you know me because I
had to learn to read like when I was 16
or something
I know those of octuple institutions and
stuff and then had a chance to do that
stuff so that's why I learned to read
that institutions and all that stuff
yeah and I thought that one thing that's
why I was um that was just really um I
opening for me like that never forgot
yeah I remember when that story came out
too that was like a [ __ ] huge story
cuz I mean you know he was such a big
player what a play I had no idea the
stats and what he did and it's also open
people's eyes on how some of the
universities beeline [ __ ] yeah yeah they
didn't educate him they they they went
based off of just his talent you know
I'm saying he's a monster just because
he was a monster yeah you know
legend yes sake I like long still a guy
like Dexter Manley right and you got
these demons man yeah do you think the
team has come with that um that depth of
skills they have yeah yeah yeah I mean
they have to because I mean you know the
things that you go through to obtain
those skills you know you know I'm
saying like the the pain that causes you
to focus on
- you know doing your skill set so that
you're the best at it but you know be
know what yeah I had never had the nerve
to do get high and do I did that one
time at the end of my career I smoked a
joint and they fined me like $300,000
for it but I had the best that was the
best friend I ever had that day I did
the most damage to anybody ever did
before broken eye socket cheekbone back
he turned around recovered yeah so focus
yeah real focus cuz that's the [ __ ] we
were talking about like it gives you a
hyper if you're one of those smokers
were like you know when you smoke it
doesn't make you like I don't want to do
[ __ ] you know I'm just relaxing lounge
and playing a video get or whatever
there's there smokers that are like that
but there's other smokers obviously that
arm way you know their functionality is
is on another level when they're smoking
like they actually do better yeah like
you know I played an NFL football games
after a man you know Matt Barnes was
telling us that you know all through his
career he was pretty much blazing
blazing before games different animal
you can be focused man you bad
yeah it's a dance but that's what I'm
saying I think you know when you smoke
before you do do whatever it is that you
do like that on on a high level of your
skill set if you're one of those
high-functioning stoners I think it
makes you focus in a lot more so like if
you're boxing right you said you felt
more relaxed you felt more focused
whereas the other you could you know I
guess maybe you could be more distracted
in that sense you know you blindsides to
be a football player
I was watching God he knocked up every
guy who makes it that far has demons and
you know [ __ ] from his past that he's
everyday trying to overcome and kill and
conquer
you know I think anybody with any sort
of talent yeah you know that that that
made it on the level that they're at you
know I'm saying yeah you have to not
only come no one no I don't think anyone
has come in squeaky clean because you
have to overcome [ __ ] to be that good to
get to those levels you know saying yeah
and I think from athletes to
entertainers they all have some sort of
some of that some way loose some people
deal with it better than others but they
all got it for sure we all got it you
know what I mean I I do believe that you
know I'm saying it's just about being
able to overcome that yeah you know
saying because everybody has you know if
you if if you have a talent and you
should be a be blessed to be able to
have some success behind it I don't
think like that no one can say that
there hasn't been one artist or athlete
that just had a squeaky clean road all
the way through you know there were
stumbles there was bumps and bruises and
all that [ __ ] beforehand and during I
mean you think about the the pain that
most athletes or entertainers have dealt
with going throughout and there's a lot
of commonalities right some of them come
from broken homes some of them didn't
have their parents at all and yet they
you know we're able to strive through
some of these things and you know not
having your parents or growing up in
foster homes and stuff like that you
know it's that's some strength that you
got to have to go through that and still
remain focused on like recognizing what
your talent is and being able to focus
on that and cue in on that and actually
make a way for yourself do that I mean
these are some strong [ __ ] that
that can do that but no you know what
they got to deal with internally unless
you're talking to somebody about the
[ __ ] that's going on with you or that
you've been through it yeah I would say
it probably makes it a harder path
because you don't feel like you got
people to relate to that or talk to you
know so you hold that in you bottle that
[ __ ] in
it could be fuel or it could be
obstacles you know I'm saying
one or the other happens in that you
know I'm Sam but yeah I think those
demons exist in all of us who do any
form of entertainment with entertainment
whether it's sports or music or all the
above you know well that's really where
the richness of life is and all that
hardship is you know when I was fighting
I was too high and frightened to think
using the drugs yeah I think functions
natural I mean that's got to it had to
be the ultimate [ __ ] feeling you know
to mean getting a hand raised and belt
around you for all for all that like a
dream for a while yeah I mean [ __ ] man I
followed your whole [ __ ] career man
super fan of the iron one you know I'm
saying thank you very much in in in your
movie III recognized something that you
you said in your movie and [ __ ] that I
was I was tripping out off of because I
saw that in the Bruce Seldon fight you
you know you were talking about how like
when you're going to the ring the dudes
already beat he's already beat you
already got him and then when you go
into the ring you looked at him and in
that moment you already knew the fight
was over you you you were speaking to
something like that it was all
psychological and you did have him beat
and you weren't talking about Bruce
Seldon in that fight it was just a
generalization how you approached every
fight I think and in the in the movie
right but when I was watching it because
I was at the cell didn't fire I was
there yeah and uh you know I had been
watching him come up and he is pretty
good fighter you know Sandhya's knocking
guys out and whatnot he had some pretty
good fights but the minute he got in the
ring he fan Boyd out now I mean he was
like oh [ __ ] I'm in the [ __ ] ring
with Mike Tyson he panicked he panicked
and you know you had him beat before he
got into the ring you had a beat and
once you guys looked at each other he
realized he was fighting his idol right
there
um I had a dad I'm a teacher he is he
was a strong influence and intimidation
I didn't understand I was only there I
first met I was so unsecured and still
shy yeah and he's got me to become this
kind of monster kind of guy he comes
with time and talking and his plan
things in my mind it was just a wild
experience yeah hmm it was crazy to see
like after after I saw your movie and
then remembering that fight I was like
[ __ ] yeah I saw that happen and now my
life I could pay for my life three
people four I guess yeah
take a look at this is a big
[ __ ] I wanted this guy wants to
[ __ ] me looks like you can [ __ ] me up
now remember when you put their eyes out
they remember that [ __ ] lots of big
dudes I mean what you're like 6 1 or 5
of them 5 10 5 10 and a half you dudes
you were fighting were like you're high
like six four six six yeah and you were
chopping trees down my bro I look up to
Marciano list informed he's got a prick
you gotta kill you physically if beat
you to death beat you to death like now
these referee stopped the fight no you
have you counted out they start to fight
the are let's guy don't quit this guy
getting [ __ ] be down you know it was a
beat you to death what was crazy when I
don't know if it was ABC um that way
back in the day they used to show those
old-school fights yeah you see those
guys yeah no stopping the fight quick
you got counted out they let you out
cold man yeah you did that you could go
down as many times as you want that
fight was continuing you ain't no three
knockdown is over man no you have 15
grams to go they they used to show all
the fights I leave an animal yeah
listen this is what you know what alley
if you're not ready to go 15 rounds
don't even go in the ring you got you're
going 15 rounds you that's because go 15
rounds you know you
do you're not knocking this guy he got a
kind of a pain tolerance under this
world can take anything you're throwing
you got it good but before that he's
gonna taking a deep water thing gonna
drown you taking the 12 13 round it'll
beat the [ __ ] out of you
he might kill you he had the stamina
here tilt up to go he gonna take your
best shot you ain't knocking this guy
out in his death
krazee-eyez a monster yeah I'm no fight
your they hold you talk about your
mother
talk about your girl your sisters are
[ __ ] sister mother's a [ __ ]
this guy's an animal you gotta fight him
on so many different levels so many
different levels
hey what did you think about the Broner
Pacquiao fight ah burner Steve he's
become a disappointment I hate to say
that about another fighter but
something's wrong is this guy taking
drugs or something he getting high
because this guy did something that was
I was offensive up one day then he
really offend me I saw him at the store
and if a game changed for some money he
said he threw the money away like I
don't need change and I'm so sensitive
growing growing up in the gutter where
he come from I'm very conscious of
something like that money means a lot
yeah you know I mean I had much more
money than he didn't have money I had
and is very conscious I would never
throw money where I would give it to a
stranger before I did somebody that's
just the conscious thing you do with
money you give it to people that's what
you know you help people with it yes
yeah and he thought he was nothing I was
just so offended by it yeah you know I
think he needs to change his panel I
don't know who might be offended but I
just rubbed me the wrong way if knowing
I came from such a disgusting place and
money was just such a such a lack of it
you know yeah yeah man you don't pack
y'all do this thing yeah I thought how
about what do you think of me whether
the best yeah really yeah and boxing
right yeah box at boxing he's definitely
the best I mean you know if you can't
touch him it's not it's not his fault if
you can't touch him yeah that seems like
anybody that goes in the ring with him
is just outclassed on everyone this
guy's been doing this
his life his father was a great fighter
never don't cool it's a grief I've been
doing this all his life man it's gonna
stall he knows this is all he knows how
to fight he's a master yeah you know it
would be interesting to see him and
Pacquiao one more time gonna be though
yeah he probably will but I'm saying you
know like analyzing what what he had did
to win that first fight you know
Pacquiao is a smart fighter you know
he's very smart
and he's quick you know he's fast how
what he what in your game plan changes
if I really look up him buddy and
disappointed me enough I didn't fight
yeah he could else maybe Floyd put him
into this way with unable to fight he
couldn't catch him he could seem like he
couldn't catch him and they're both fast
as [ __ ] it's just you know like if one
guy is a little bit faster you know what
you gonna do it's just hard to beat but
it would be intriguing to see that [ __ ]
again because I mean you know who else
who else who else cuz I mean we're gonna
do Conor again this is a young guy
coming up named arrow Spence right this
guy's the real deal for years yeah he's
a walk away on the flu Simon pound I
believe he can no one could beat him
right now but I'm telling he'd be a big
star in a few years you continue to stay
in that path Mike could you ever train
somebody this takes a special person to
do that yeah yeah a person like that
have to be so subconscious and only to
fight I am I think about myself too much
maybe hmm
that's why most fighters um they can't
fight train that's really difficult
it's like though you go away and this
focus everything on this individual you
live your life through him it's like
some play like like basketball players
some of them can play the game but they
can't coach even though they have all
the skill set to teach someone it's like
you know it's like when magic tried to
coach it's how you related yeah I tried
coaching I went back to my high school
and coach was the assistant a line coach
man and I couldn't do it yeah and then
you got to connect with all those
different personalities well
and get him how you know figuring out
how to make them work together yeah you
know and then disconnected yourself from
the actual game so you're not like
feeling like yeah you're in there yeah
like this is what I would do if I was in
there why aren't you doing it and yeah
yeah coaching on that level that it's a
[ __ ] heavy you know it's a [ __ ]
big burden to deal with it is it's a big
task did you guys watch the Superbowl
good for you my host on YouTube baby
that's a show okay it's a show right
there did you watch it be I did I did
you know
are you Rams fan I am a Rams fan I mean
hey you know Tom Brady baby Tom Brady
you know it's it's hard to beat the goat
but I'll say this
you know it was a tough game on both
ends like in terms of the defenses were
[ __ ] defenses killing it yeah you
know the young guy he could you know he
couldn't golf get the rhythm yeah golf
couldn't get his rhythm going it's hard
to be Brady man listen right I'm just
being honest this is my and I know
people say that their team demand team
listen I saw him play Atlanta one time
they played in Atlanta you were there
for that no I was on you're watching
watching it watch this one was gonna win
would have a black team really Wayne
yeah black team's one for black but this
is a real black team this is black
Atlanta right so they're gonna win and
listen they ran they brand they beat the
[ __ ] out of Tom Brady no way they're
gonna lose yeah it's no way they can
lose how could they lose eating the [ __ ]
out of them oh man this guy found out
what happened to but he woke up with
something start throwing a baby won't
he's a warrior
well he's a warrior and his experience
you know what I mean because I mean both
defenses were playing great like they
were doing what they were supposed to do
it's just
Brady found a way to win yeah
yeah in golf you know for that third
year to be in a Super Bowl against the
greatest quarterback of all time come on
for sure you know but they did they did
[ __ ] you know they did great through
the season and I believe they'll be
there again well Tom Brady now has the
most Super Bowl rings of anybody's got
six right yeah yeah oh that's some [ __ ]
talking he got the franchise on the
other sideline across from him and have
watched him just surgically deconstruct
my team's defense you know what's crazy
is there's bets in Vegas on all that
[ __ ] okay like for instance when they're
gonna show his girl right and they
showed her in the third quarters oh yes
they showed gizelle in the third quarter
you know and immediately they go back to
the field he [ __ ] throws for a
touchdown or whatever the [ __ ] that was
yeah that ball that groan yeah he just
dropped it in there - it wasn't [ __ ] it
was like it was like magic I show this
they show his lady up his wife up there
and then BOOM [ __ ] makes a big play
it was like magic you know watching that
I was like get the [ __ ] out of here
hey listen I'm a Rams fan but I'll give
it up to him
I'll give it up to him you know he's
he's a champ yes Tom Brady the legend
goat you know well it was gonna take
golf having a great game for the Rams to
win yeah and he didn't have one neither
girly-girly what I don't understand the
game plan they [ __ ] kept him out of
the game for the first half
CJ Anderson - they didn't like work him
enough cuz that dude was punching holes
through lines you know they were calling
it true like the commentators right they
were saying that Belichick was pretty
much throwing like fake pressure out
there yeah to confuse homie because I
mean you know hey it's a three year in
the league you know quarterback this is
a huge game he's probably filled with
some nerves most definitely filled with
some nerves as poised as he's been up to
that moment that's the [ __ ] Super
Bowl
so obviously he used a little bit of
that poker you know playing poker with
you know faking pressure on him and he
you know it worked
through the whole [ __ ] game he
couldn't get started Belichick did what
he does best
yeah he just [ __ ] him up but I'll say
this defensive coach um
oh wait Phil laid Phillips yes he
[ __ ] had a great yeah defensive game
plan
defense defense awesome did great up
until that fourth quarter you know yeah
well dude you're gonna give up someplace
to yet to Grady to Brady you know I mean
their coaches are saying that all week
they're like they're gonna get their
plays he had two they had two great
weapons yeah you know I'm saying we had
some too but we couldn't get him off hey
talking about coaches and mentors if you
find anybody out there there there's a
kid you know well he's not a kid a dude
we we met some years back he's been
working with his his named emmerich and
I've did some projects with him with
Cypress you know and with with the
exhibit we did a some some albums under
the name serial killers and he's he's
one of the dudes that like you know I
think people sleep on that is very dope
versatile you know artist he can get on
any type of track he can do the nate
dogg [ __ ] too and and sing as well you
know I'm saying so like he got bars and
he can sing and you know I think
[ __ ] need to [ __ ] with Tim what
do you got going in the cannabis space
man well we just recently opened up uh
well not recently last last August we we
opened up our first dispensary doctor
green thumbs and Sylmar we got that shop
opening we're opening up another one in
Palm Springs up in or actually Cathedral
City and we're gonna try fine yeah yeah
California and then we're gonna try to
open one open you know a few more here
in calcutta rats
yeah yeah and congratulations on that
man thank you I know my [ __ ] are like
way too hyped on that just because you
know some of us knew you got stoned when
of us talked about it because back then
nobody blew each other up nobody did
these days it's like one of those things
were like everybody's trying to scoop
everybody out and spill some [ __ ] now
these you know that the social networks
that exist that mean that's all is for
now I remember the first time I see one
of those phones that you could take
pictures of or you know because there
was no video yet I was in Europe we were
with on a tour with Eminem 50-cent
exhibit g-unit and all that I think I
was anger management tour and we were in
some city and I was it one of my other
bandmates and now we're walking through
the like market area and this dude had
his phone up like doing selfie mode like
you know doing a selfie he had it high
up and I could see him look I could see
him looking at us and like trying to
position himself and and and I saw that
and I thought it was weird but I saw
that he had his phone and I walked over
to him like a man what are you doing and
you know I was just I was just tripping
out on what he was doing cuz I know he
was doing our direction
I wasn't like offended or anything
because like I'm cool with fans like I
don't trip I'll take pictures with him
sign autographs all that [ __ ] but I was
just like you know like what are you
doing and he's like oh I'm sorry um I
was just taking a picture of you guys
ever but I'm like taking a picture and
it would know it was like I hadn't seen
a [ __ ] a phone that you know you
could take photos with yet you know
because those those are those phones
weren't in America yet you know say we
stand I saw that [ __ ] and I and I was
like you can't live without those phones
yeah you could take a picture with your
phone he goes yeah look and it was like
the first time I seen a selfie right
again true this was not in America yet
but I saw that and I was like oh [ __ ]
it's over now Wow it's over and look I
mean look what it is totally normal
it's it's totally the [ __ ] to do right
yeah I mean people ain't even caught
like slick about
it's just blatant yeah it's crazy I
always thought my time if I had this
doing when I was fighting and stuff I
would have pictures a lot because a lot
of people I've met are celebrity men
hung out with a guy one man if I had
pictures no a little crazy right never
took pictures yeah they're those that
technology came to way too [ __ ] late
for all the good [ __ ] that they could
have saw it happened in the 90s bro yeah
80s and 90s were crazy it's probably
good probably is good you're right yeah
for some yeah what do you guys think
about all that what do you guys think
about cuz you were really like I mean
you saw the first selfie man yeah well
with you guys in Europe I saw that you
know what I mean at least I saw what was
gonna come yeah cuz I knew they had it
we were we were bound to have it and
sure enough maybe like two three months
later we had those phones you know and
they just got better and better and
[ __ ] better you imagine right you
know like the technology that we haven't
even seen that you know the federal
government tests before it releases out
that on the military-grade technology
that's the work foot official
intelligent everybody have to do our job
I mean think about it they got drones
now they could do a job and not put a
pilot you know and they're they're
conscious conscience you know in the in
the center of if they had to go release
some weaponry on somebody you know I'm
saying they got drones they could do
that so there's there's a whole lot of
[ __ ] out there that who we haven't seen
and we're going to eventually I have to
the toad the toad yeah was that
scientific where five Meo DMT comes from
that you can smoke all right right the
tone yes nor in desert toad and they
harvest its venom for this five Meo DMT
which people vaporize in these
ceremonies it's much like ayahuasca or
something like that but it's condensed
to 15 minutes
right blast off go talk to God and come
back or whatever after this yes the
Eifel few moments you experience an ego
death you you know see [ __ ] that you
need to see and over some things and and
that's something everybody goes through
through that right everything everyone
is different but those are kind of main
points of my experience you know and
then you come out of it and you feel
rejuvenated the plan Basin Plan B's is
fun - yeah fun I like the toe but it's
fine have you ever done anything like
that well we should do mushrooms yeah we
haven't done any of that yet yeah yeah
they're the same family I mean DMT it's
another it's we actually created in our
pineal gland yeah which our third eye
this doctor who came on to talk to us
about it he said that they've discovered
that there's two times when we get a hit
of it naturally and that's when we're
formed in the womb right mother's womb
and then on the day honor when we die
the beginning and then Obadiah God Alpha
and Omega right yeah yeah so right you
know it's very powerful they think it's
like the doorway or the passageway that
our soul a lot of people tell me that
you know a lot of people tell me that
they go on a journey and they see
different things and if you know for
everybody obviously it's different yeah
but they always come like the the main
the commonality with the people that
I've known that done it is they've come
it come out of it with some clarity
about yeah something about themselves
like either ability or something you
know what I mean I have not experienced
it yet but like I had a few friends that
they tell me that same thing you know
yeah and you know it's interesting and
who knows that you know yeah I'm always
like open to
you know new things yeah although I
haven't you know done mushrooms in acid
in many [ __ ] years but yeah you know
you think you away from it because that
other stuff is just I feel like she
waiting people that love you yeah yeah
for sure
well those ego building ready to die
yeah yeah living on the edge for a I
can't believe I'm doing this stuff you
know me live in the dream hey it's great
man and it's nice to see you doing it
you know I mean because you're somebody
like you know a lot of people don't know
but you smoked for real you chief that's
you know the the obviously throwing
during your career you could say it or
do it in front of people because they
were testing and and all that [ __ ] was
was happening but I mean you know you're
a stoner so it's good to see it's good
to see you in the game so people know it
you know and I know I could say it cuz
I've seen it and I've chiefed out with
you before and it's real you notice it
because what happens I know and this in
the cannabis game is so many people are
entering the the industry now right
there's an influx of all kinds of
different celebrities right coming in
and some of them don't [ __ ] with it at
all this they're just looking at it
about the money and hell yeah the
money's gonna be great but it's great
when somebody that's really about it
is is getting into it because you know
it's like they appreciate it stuff
because we love it we appreciate it
yes we'll make some [ __ ] money but
like we love it you know as opposed to
[ __ ] were just looking at it
like I'm and this is just you know this
is been doing it without money for free
yeah for real I mean for real man so
yeah with that being said awesome but
you guys got to come up to dr. green
thumbs one yeah for sure but we got to
definitely do that smoke box
new artists out here you want to
collaborate with unlike me goes I like
me goes are like Drake alike yeah they
did get down I've seen them play like
Kendrick I like J Cole live concert yeah
he severed he's good yeah we got to come
to the kind festival to man if you're
free yeah yell the headline when is it
February 23rd yeah I think we'll be on
tour actually we're we're gonna be on
tour with Hollywood Undead
from February through March but you know
we'll get a get down together man we're
doing another one in October ah I'll be
around in October perfect yeah awesome
man really hey I'm totally down whatever
whatever you guys doing count me in I'm
down nice well [ __ ] man we really
appreciate you coming thanks for having
me and I gotta have you guys in the
smoke box man oh definitely
well schedule it yes we got to make that
happen man oh yeah mouth smug back
anything you want to shout out before we
get out of here you know check out dr.
green thumbs Cypress Hill got a new
album called elephants on acid right now
oh yeah and it's an album where it
sounds like an acid trip without being
on acid yeah yeah oh yeah awesome
brother thank you for having me thank
you man it's good to see you Anna to
thank word up man all right y'all until
next time we're out of here I'm Mike
Tyson I'm Evan Britain I'll be real yeah
peace
[Music]